bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoint dans
filecoo l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les grandes
lignes de cette émission les salariés de
Fujifilm médical système toujours en
attente des modalités de leur plan
social nous ferons le point sur leur
situation
one nation Paris profite de sa nouveauté
pour attirer les consommateurs les
chiffres de fréquentation dépassent les
espérances des commerçants nous
parlerons reprise d'entreprise reprendre
plutôt que de créer quel intérêt quel
défi à relever nous avons rencontré pour
notre dossier de la semaine des
repreneurs yvelinois et puis nous ferons
le point sur la situation des
commerçants du centre des gaâtines à
plaisir le mois dernier 5 commerces
avaient été incendiés nous recevons sur
notre plateau Michel louvri bonsoir vous
êtes artisan bouché et franc pensou
bonsoir propriétaire de de certains des
commerces touchés on vous retrouve dans
un instant après l'actualité économique
de la
semaine nous vous parlions dans le
journal télévisé de mardi des salariés
de Fujifilm médical systemme France basé
à Montini le Bretonneux ils avaient
entamé un mouvement de grève illimité
ils se disent inquiets quant à leur
avenir leurs revendications n'ont pas
changé comme vous allez le voir des
images de Patrick jaaces de
dixmud si salariés de Fujifilm médical
système France sont en colère lundi ils
protestaient contre une réorganisation
du groupe et l'annonce d'un PSE un plan
de sauvegarde de l'entreprise 53
suppressions de postees en France et 30
1 salariés de Montini appelés à
travailler sur le site danière le siège
social des annonces qui inquiètent on ne
sait pas encore en fait dans quelles
conditions les gens vont aller sur
anière et dans quelles conditions les
gens vont partir pour ceux qui ne
pourront pas suivre pour la direction de
cette entreprise d'imagerie médicale le
but est de regrouper physiquement les
activités endoscopie et radiologie et
pas lié à la baisse d'activité en fait
c'est un petit peu le changement qui a
connu la photo quand on est parti de
l'AR est pass l'Argenti numérique qui
maintenant arrive en radiologie où on
passe de Argentine également en
numérique avec toutes les conséquences
économiques que çaela peut avoir et donc
dans ce dans ce cadre là nous sommes
obligés de réorganiser la société la
directe a cependant demandé à
l'entreprise d'apporter des
modifications sur les modalités
d'accompagnement et les indemnités de
départ sur Montini près de 80 % des
salariés étaient en grève jusqu'à
mercredi ils ont repris aujourd'hui
l'activité après avoir rencontré leur
direction sur le site danière par contre
la mobilisation continue de nouvelles
modalités devraient être proposé à
l'ensemble des salariés ce
vendredi le paquet de cigarettes à 7 €
une nouvelle barre franchie ce lundi
suite à la dernière hausse du prix du
tabac comment réagissent buralistes et
consommateurs réponse avec ce reportage
réalisé avec Patrick Jacques du
dixm nouvelle hausse du prix du tabac ce
lundi la 3è en 15 mois les paquets de
cigarettes ont augmenté de 20 centimes
le plus vendu est ainsi passé en
quelques années de 5 à 7 €. les paquets
de tabac à roulé sur lesquels se
reportter certains consommateurs
augmentent quant à eux de 50 centimes
une envolée des prix qui inquiète les
buralistes encore une haosese qui nous
frappe de plein fouet égal baisse du
volume donc baisse de chiffre d'affaires
parce que aujourd'hui contrairement aux
années précédente euh l'augmentation du
du prix ne compensera pas la perte de
volume
l'année dernière les ventes de tabac ont
déjà chuté de 7,7 % une victoire pour le
gouvernement qui souhaite voir la
consommation de tabac diminué par mesure
de santé publique mais pour les
consommateurs rencontrés cette hausse ne
les poussera pas à arrêter de fumer
celui qui fume depuis 30 ans il va pas
s'arrêter le jour de lendemain aucune
efficacité non on va aller à l'étranger
chercher nos cigarettes main temp là
c'est moins cher tout simplement en
France près de 25 % du tabac consommé
proviendrait de réseau parallèles pour
le gouvernement les taxes soit 80 % du
prix d'achat du tabac permettent de
financer notamment l'assurance maladie
des travailleurs salariés 73000
personnes meurent chaque année du tabac
et une autre difficulté frappe les
buralistes les salariés du fournisseur
de tabac pour l'Île-deFrance sont
actuellement en grève cela fait
maintenant 8 jours qu'il réclame une
augmentation de salaire au chaîné ou
encore à Montini des buralistes sont
actuellement en rupture de stock lundi
les buralistes n'étaient pas pas les
seuls en colère les taxis parisiens
étaient en grève ils protestaient contre
la hausse de la TVA et la concurrence
qu'ils estiment déloyale des véhicules
véhicules pardon de tourisme avec
chauffeurs les VTC pas de mouvement à
noter dans le département mais à 5-quen1
en Yveline les taxis souignent les mêmes
difficultés aujourd'hui le le prix comme
partout c'est le nerf de la guerre donc
plus vous êtes cher moins vous avez
client et la concurrence effectivement
moins ils ont de contraintte et moins
ils ont de charg plus ils peuvent faire
des prix bas donc automatiquement pour
nous c'est et c'est effectivement des
choses qui sont pas pas pas formidables
et on n pas le choix parce que nous les
tarifs il faut savoir également que
quand on fait quand on apppplique pas
les augmentation de tarif on nous
verbalise bah ensuite c'est vrai qu'on
est quand même contrôlé souvent on a des
des compteurs on est plombé il y a il y
a comment dire vis médical et autres
enfin il y a beaucoup de contraintes que
les autres n'ont pas
visiblement première solde pour l'outl
de luxe one nation et premier baptême du
feu pour les commerçants le centre
commercial des clés sous-bois a connu
une grosse affluence sur surtout ce
weekend contrastant avec le bilan plutôt
mitigé des autres enseignes reportage
Olivier Maniscalco et Patrick Jacques
dCK smid nous venons de de selogne parce
qu'on avait entendu parler effectivement
de ce
centre de marque dégriffé et en plus en
sold donc c'est c'est vrai que c'est
c'est super intéressant
il on a les bras un peu
chargés oui tout dépend pour qui voilà
même si le premier bilan des soldes
divers semble mitigé pour les enseignes
de mode avec une baisse de chiffre
d'affaires de 5 à 10 % en France à one
nation Paris au clés sous-bois on semble
ne pas connaître la crise avec 80000
visiteurs du 8 au 12 janvier les tiroirs
caisses se sont bien remplis pour ce
nouveau complexe que les clients
viennent découvrir un nouvel équipement
commercial dans une zone qui est déjà
très populaire donc bien sûr ça a joué
ce qui a surtout joué je pense c'est le
fait que nos prix sont tous les jours
très bas on a mo-s 30 % de démarque tous
les jours et les soldes vient de
s'appliquer sur ces prix déjà démarqués
donc les gens l'ont compris des gens qui
pourtant peuvent bénéficier toute
l'année de promotion via les sites
internet spécialisés ou les nombreuses
boutiques qui proposent régulièrement
des Rabet intéressants mais là encore
l'effet nouveauté du centre semble
opérer je pense que ça fausse un peu la
donne parce que certains clients V être
beaucoup moins impatient de manière
générale vu qu'il y a des soldes un peu
toute l'année des soldes flottantes on
va dire que les les clients qui sont
venus sont venus pour acheter parce
qu'il sa ils avaient fait du repérage
avant la période des soldes euh donc
qu'on a une hausse de peu près 10 % au
niveau de fréquentation par contre le
chiffre on est passé du simple au double
VO même au triple selon les journées
autre explication des bons chiffres les
navettes gratu mises en place depuis
Paris pour transporter les clients vers
les boutiques il vous reste jusqu'au 11
février date de la fin des soldes pour
en
profiter soulagé par la baisse de la TVA
de - 7 de 7 pardon à 5,5 % la Fédération
Nationale des Cinémas Français a décidé
de proposer des places de cinéma à 4 €
pour les moins de 14 ans mais est-ce que
cela va réellement changer les choses
pour les salles élément de réponse
Anthony Resche et Patrick Jacques de
dixmud les familles sont les grands
gagnants de la baisse de la TVA
désormais lorsque vous emmènerez vos
enfants au cinéma leur place vous
coûtera 4 €. un nouveau prix dû à la
diminution de la taxe pour le grand
écran de 7 à 5,5 %. mais cette offre
mettrait en difficulté les petites
salles qui se démarquer jusqu'à présent
par des tarifs attractifs et qui
dénoncent un gros manque à gagner on
peut prtiquer des tarifs plus bas donc
permettre à plus de monde de venir dans
les salles mais nous ça va encore nous
baisser encore un petit peu bon un tout
petit peu plus cher mais ça va encore
nous baisser un tout petit peu ça va
jouer sur notre chiffre d'affaires quoi
et comme on sait qu'on a des chiffres
d'affaires qui sont un peu ricraac c'est
un peu difficile ça va surtout profiter
au grand circuit grâce à des conventions
signées avec les villes d'élancour et
morpa les jeunes habitants de ces
communes payent déjà leur place au CC
entre 2,50 € et 3 € cette offre à 4 €
est aussi une manière d'inciter les
Français à revenir dans les salle dont
la fréquentation ne devrait pas dépasser
les 200 millions d'entrées en 2013 soit
10 % de moins qu'en 2011 malgré l'effet
d'annonce cette baisse de la TVA est en
réalité un simple retour à la taxation
de 2012 la tranche des 6 14 ans
représente à l'heure actuelle près de 10
% des clients des salles obscures cette
opération de réduction de la TVA devrait
coûter près de 20 millions d'euros à
l'industrie du cinéma français diretion
maintenant l'université de Versailles
SaintQuentin hier hier pardon mardi se
tenait un conseil d'administration afin
de voter le budget 2014 il a été accepté
par le Conseil mais rejeté par le
rectorat car présenté en déséquilibre de
7 millions d'euros ce qui est contraire
au Code de l'éducation l'université a
maintenant un mois pour présenter un
nouveau budget la réaction de Jean-Luc
vessère recueilli lors de la cérémonie
des vœux de
l'agglomération maintenant on va rentrer
dans une phase de négociation avec le
ministère puisque un buéquilibre c'est
un peu innovant le ministère s'est
engagé à nous accompagner dans notre
plan de retour à l'équilibre sur
plusieurs années a priori 3 ans donc
voilà donc le ministère va nous aider en
terme de trésorerie pour pouvoir aller
progressivement vers l'équilibre mais
voilà il s pas engagé à nous mettre plus
d'argent comme ça donc ce sera peut-être
des avances remboursabl ultérieurement
quand la situation sera rétablie voilà
j'aurais pu pas présenter de budget
laisser le recteur faire ce qu'il
voulait faire des coupes mais je pense
que c'était ê responsable que de
présenter ce Budet responsable vis-à-vis
du ministère responsable par rapport à
communauté par rapport aussi mon
objectif c'est de pas aller pas faire de
coupe supplémenta ou vraiment très
marginalement une dernière formation le
groupe Safran installera cette année son
nouveau centre de recherche à
Châteaufort et manier lamoau un bâtiment
de 44000 m car doit accueillir 1500
salariés du groupe on passe maintenant à
l'entretien le 8 décembre dernier un
incendie a ravagé le centre commercial
des gaâtines plaisir au total 5
commerces touchés qui ont dû fermer
boutique un mois et demi plus tard
quelle est leur situation quand
pourront-ils reprendre leur activité je
vous propose de faire le point avec nos
invités nous recevons sur notre plateau
Michel ellouvri bonsoir vous êtes
artisan boucher votre commerce fait donc
partie des enseignes qui ont été
incendié puis à vos côté Franck pensau
bonsoir propriétaire de certains des des
commerces touchés également donc la la
nouvelle avait choqué pas mal de monde
vous-même vous l'aviez appris comment
moi je l'avais appris par par téléphone
à la maison parce que mes frigos sont
reliés à la maison si une coupure de
courant c'est comme ça qu'on était prévu
le matin aujourd'hui du coup votre
activité est totalement cessé depuis 8
décembre ça j'imagine que ça représente
un manque à gagn important surtout sur
le mois de décembre c'est un des mois
les plus lours de l'année quand même
pour l'instant pas de rentrée d'argent
les assurances ne suivent pas on attend
les assurances on attend les retours des
experts mais c'est long c'est long c'est
long et en attendant vous Contin
continuer à avoir des frais final bien
sr lesais fix
continuou c'est le problème mais bon
vous de votre côté du coup vous êtes
propriétaire le le manque à gagné pour
vous c'est la loocation des des locaux
tout à fait pour l'instant on a une
manque un manque à gagner des locations
mais on sait qu'on est assuré totalement
donc le plus important pour moi
aujourd'hui c'est surtout les locataires
surtout Michel qui a depuis 30 ans qui
est le plus impacté pour moi alors c'est
les les assurances donc du coup on
réagit quand même assez rapidement les
expertises ont été rapide oui mais c'est
la suite finalement qui Fa un peu oui
c'est vrai qu' les 15 jours de fê qu'on
pas mal bloqué les choses c'est normal
mais depuis ça fait quand même 15 jours
il se passe pas grand-chose alors la
solution là aujourd'hui ce serait
d'installer du coup des préfabriqués
c'est ce qu'on envisage ouais c'est
absolument ou à la limite de garder
pouvoir dépanner nos clients sur place
et de rester un peu sur place alors
avant de développer justement sur ce
point je vous propose d'écouter la la
mère de plaisir qui qui évoque cette
possibilité et qui explique ce que la
ville peut mettre à disposition de de
vos commerces on l'écoute nous nous
sommes engagés bien sûr à avoir un
accompagnement alors un accompagnement
qui ne peut être qu'un accompagnement je
dirais restreint dans le sens que c'est
du privé et nous sommes du public mais
bien évidemment la ville les présent à à
leur côté ce qui s'est passé c'est que
le 20 décembre nous avons reçu ici
effectivement certains certains
responsables de chez Casino qui souhait
aujourd'hui mettre en place une
commercialisation je dirais un petit peu
plus comment dire plus légère avec des
algco des algco de qualité nous bien sûr
on leur a mis à disposition tout e notre
capacité d'aide administrative et aussi
la possibilité de s'installer sur
l'espace public puisque bien évidemment
hors de question d'imaginer qu'on puisse
demander quoi que ce soit alors l'espace
public c'est le le parking j'imagine
tout à fait oui plus devant les magasins
au même endroit même emplacement donc là
vous allez peut-être vous arranger on va
dire avec le casino tout à fait on va
essayer de faire chamb chambre commune
si jeose dire et se regrouper tous les
deux pour pour au moins faire face
pendant pendant les 10 mois à venir
alors pour vous c'est compliqué vous
êtes boucher ça veut dire également
avoir une chambre froide avoir et ouais
il faut que j'installe une chambre
froide à mon domicile il faut que
j'arrive à avoir des vitrines
réfrigérées c'est ouais c'est assez
compliqué puis puis une place restreinte
une place restreinte du coup ça ne pose
pas de problème au niveau de la
législation non non on va rester dans
les normes ça de ce côté-là il y a pas
de problème on va rester tout à fait
dans les normes concernant les les
commerces les autres commerces puisque
vous êtes aussi du coup responsable
aujourd'hui du du syndicat c'est bien ça
tout à fait je suis pr président du
syndic aujourd'hui on va se battre
surtout pour tout ce qui est locataire
moi je vais me battre au maximum j'ai
souvent je suis j'ai souvent Mme Barra
qui est responsable du syndicque j'ai
tous les l'architectes en en ligne on
essaie d'être assez souvent en ligne je
l'ai eu une fois ou deux les assurances
font le maximum mais aujourd'hui c'est
vrai qu'on est sur un point où il y a
une attente on est bloqué c'est je
j'essaie d'avoir madame madame Barra qui
est difficile à joindre aujourd'hui
parce qu'elle essaie de faire le maximum
avec les assurances on a un assureur
d'assuré qui est formidable que je peux
avoir à la minute qui va bien me
renseigner qui va essayer de voilà on va
tout faire faire ce qu'on peut
aujourd'hui pour que ça aille très vite
la démolition on estime qu'elle va durer
elle va être proposée on va essayer de
voir ave madame le Maire si on peut
l'avoir dans 2 mois la fabrication la
commencement des le commencement des
travaux on espère début juin la
finalisation fin décembre c'est le le
délai qu'on a pour l'instant pour tous
les commerces ça pourra se faire en
parallèle pour tous les pour tous les
commerces pour les diff tout à fait en
fin de compte c'est tous les commerces
en même temps on rase on refait
entièrement le bâtiment donc la
structure à l'identique et on est tout
au normes alors vous voulez même
améliorer du coup l'endroit le lieu quel
quelles améliorations pardon vous voulez
apporter alors comme comme j'évoqué à
Michel il y a pas longtemps comme je
suis co-président du syndic depuis peu
je vais m'efforcer avec le président à
faire le maximum pour faire un renouveau
mettre du camerops faire quelque chose
de joli faire une course sympathique
redonner de du dynamisme refaire un
local poubelle qui n'y avait pas on va
refaire plein de choses possies mettre
des caméras parce que malheureusement on
l'a évoqué mais ça pas été voté on va
mettre des barrière à l'arrière parce
qu'on est propriétaire de l'arrière donc
on a chement des voitures qui viennent
se stationner des jeunes et cetera c'est
normal mais bon on va essayer de bloquer
tout ça de faire un centre un peu fermé
mais quand même attra le plus libre et
attractif possible donc faire beaucoup
de pub madame le Maire m'a autorisé à
mettre une pancarte dernièrement je
remercie encore beaucoup madame le Maire
sur le rondpo des gaâtines juste à côté
euh voir si on peut le faire mais avec
bien marqué laané nomination de chaque
commerce et dire qu'il y a aussi un
centre commercial donc Mme le Maire fait
tout
elle est extraordinaire je le dis bien
parce que elle nous accorde tout pour
l'instant après c'est à voir si tout se
réalise mais je remercie beaucoup et ces
bancardes pourront aussi aider les
commerces actuellement en place qui qui
continuent finalement leur activité et
qui connaissent finalement un gros
manque à gagner du fait de votreidement
reste plus qu'à deux c'est pas facile
hein même pour ceux qui restent c'est
pas simple il va avoir une perte de
chiffres énorme c'est c'est obligatoire
les gens sont obligés chercher ailleurs
ils font leur courses ailleurs c'est
c'est humain c'est normal ça c'est même
nous il faudra qu'on arrive à r dononner
l'habitude aux gens de revenir parce que
des habitudes vont se prendre sur un an
il faudra un certain lapse de temps pour
qu'on retrouve nos repères et qu'on
retrouvent nos clients et et que tout
rentre dans l'ordre vous êtes tout de
même là depuis longtemps vous êtes oui
ça fait 28 ans que je suis au même
endroit moi oui oui oui on a on a bien
suivi l'évolution du quartier quand même
mais bon al ce qui est dommage c'est
finalement vous m'indiquiez tout à
l'heure 2013 a été votre meilleur ami
très très bonne année la reconnaissance
absolument on avait s associé une
nouvelle enseigne ouais qui pour avoir
une super traçabilité des produits des
produits vraiment de qualité et tout les
gens étaient très réceptifs on ait fait
deux trois animations ça s'était très
très bien passé mais bon bah tout est
coupé pour l'instant on va essayer de
redémarrer avec eux le plus tôt possible
ils feront toujours parti on sera
toujours avec eux ils seront toujours
avec nous on verra bien c'est pas
finalement l'élan n'est pas coupé en
plein vol ça Perm for fré on va dire on
va essayer de rebondir absolument de
toute façon c'est c'est pour nous
survivre on est obligé de rebondir on
peut pas vivre de nos rent c'est pas
possible très déjà 12 mois ça risque
d'être très long très long et très
compliqué on espère en tout cas que que
les assurances du coup débloqueront la
situation le plus rapidement et on se
tiendra informé des réouvertures
prochain oui on aura besoin d'aide à ce
moment-là ou absolument qu'on fasse du
tapage et la
fêteble faut que les locomotives
arrivent parce que Michel est une
locomotive du centre commercial
maintenant qu'il est parti on a il y a
trois locomotives et deux locomotives
sont partis donc aujourd'hui on se bat
pour ce cent commercial qui revienn un
petit peu qui revivent et ben on
l'espère très prochainement merci
beaucoup à tous les deux de d'avoir été
avec nous sur notre plateau merci à vous
on passe au dossier de la
semaine les futurs chefs d' d'entreprise
sont généralement confronté à deux choix
soit créer leur société de A à Z soit
reprendre une structure existante
reprendre une entreprise c'est partir
d'un acquis prendre moins de risqu mais
c'est aussi l'occasion de développer une
société voire même de lui donner un
nouveau souffle nous avons rencontré des
ivelinois qui ont fait ce choix de la
reprise d'entreprise ils nous racontent
leur expérience un reportage de yolen
Torz et de la de la rédaction pardon à
25 ans Guillaume vient tout juste de
devenir son propre patron depuis le 1er
novembre avec sa femme Sabrina il est le
propriétaire de cette boucherie
installée à Montini le Bretonneux je
vais ristre trois fois par semaine pour
acheter tout ce qui est la viande tout
ce qui la volaille donc ça prend
beaucoup de temps de l'énergie ça je
savais mais je pens pas dépenser autant
d'énergie en étant patron ce jeune
sartoi est dans le métier depuis 10 ans
il a commencé en apprentissage passer
ses diplômes puis il est monté sur Paris
pour peaufiner son expérience après 5
ans en tant que salarié dans une
boucherie de ville d'AVR il a rapidement
voulu avoir son propre commerce j'aime
pas être dirigé j'aime pas avoir
quelqu'un a dessus de moi donc et c'est
depuis longtemps que ça me trotte dans
l'idée bon faut avoir faut avoir de
l'argent de côté il faut avoir beaucoup
de conditions en fait pour pour
reprendre une entreprise ça se fait pas
du jour au lendemain pour céder
Guillaume fait appel à un marchand de
fond un agent spécialisé dans la vente
de fond de commerce le couple avait déjà
quelques critères bien précis en tête
faut regarder si a du passage faut
regarder comment est la boutique si elle
est propre ou pas propre si elle est
bien entretenue si il y a une rotation
dans la viande puis il faut regarder les
bilans après dès la première visite
c'est le coup de cœur la ville leur
plaît la place aussi de mois après ils
emménagent démarre leur nouvelle
activité avec eux Kevin un des salariés
de l'ancienne équipe cela faisait un an
que l'exgérant cherchait le bon client
désormais à la retraite c'est en toute
confiance qu'il leur a cédé sa clientèle
moi ça me fait plaisir parce que c'est
des jeunes donc on a beaucoup de mal à
trouver des jeunes là c'est des jeunes
qui sont très motivés apparemment très
professionnels aussi ils ont bien
travaillé tous les deux de leur côté et
ils connaissent bien le métier bien
connaître le métier un point important
pour obtenir des financements plus
facilement premier étape indispensable
c'est être issu du secteur
d'activité les projets de reprise dont
leurpreneur n'est pas issu soit de
formation soit par expérience sont plus
difficiles à financer par les banques
deuxième étape importante pour les
banques le repreneur doit pouvoir verser
un apport d'environ 30 % minimum en
fonction du montant de la reprise un
montant fixé par le céd puis négocié
avec le repreneur il est aussi possible
de faire appel à un comité d'évaluation
comme celui de la Chambre des Métiers et
de l'Artisanat pour connaître la valeur
du commerce leur méthode la plus
courante est de fixer un barê brut en
fonction de l'activité et du chiffre
d'affaires annuel de la Société
Guillaume a choisi de reprendre une
entreprise et non pas d'en créer une car
la création lui paraît plus compliquée
ça demande beaucoup plus de papier de de
recherche faut trouver les locaux après
faut trouver la personne qui veulent
bien nous nous financer parce que c'est
très très cher de de faire une boucherie
tout le matériel est très cher et non je
préfè prendre quelque chose puce qu'on a
déjà une base en fait on a déjà une base
de clientèle je connaissais déjà les
anciens propriétaires et je B je suis
resté fidèle à la aux nouveaux arrivants
avec la même satisfaction pour le moment
donc j'espère que ça va durer
aujourd'hui dans le département des
ivelines 40 % des chefs d'entreprise
artisanales seraient en âge de partir à
la retraite la reprise d'entreprise
constitue donc un enjeu important du
côté des reeneur le volume n'est
peut-être pas aussi important
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup plus de
personnes de porteurs de projet qui vont
vers un projet de création d'entreprise
classique plutôt que de penser à un
projet de reprise pourtant les avantages
d'une reprise sont bien là à sur le
responsable le taux de pérennité est
beaucoup plus important chez les
repreneurs et contrairement à ce que
l'on pourrait penser reprendre une
entreprise n'est pas un frein à
l'innovation le nouveau chef
d'entreprise il va pouvoir y mettre sa
touche il va pouvoir y mettre sa patte
et développer de nouveaux services de de
nouvelles manières de
fonctionner remettre en question un peu
les fournisseurs et cetera la clientèle
elle est là l'objectif c'est de garder
cette clientèle et d'en développer une
nouvelle donc forcément pour en
développer une nouvelle il va falloir
trouver nouveau moyen la conquérir donc
l'innovation alors c'est pas que
l'innovation technologique mais
l'innovation de service ça peut être une
manière d'aller plus loin aller plus
loin c'est justement ce qu'a voulu faire
manuel si elle est complètement déchargé
il faut prévoir au moins 2 2 à 3 heur
minimum pour qu'elle soit
opérationnelle 53 ans il est aujourd'hui
le cgérant de cette société de
réparation et de vente de véhicules à
plaisir une société qu'il a d'abord
connu en tant que salarié pendant 31 ans
là on a créé un atelier qui n'était pas
existant non plus avant les réparations
s'effectuent on va dire presque presque
en plein airz tout créé en fait voilà on
a tout recréé en 3 ans de temps on a
créé un atelier qui fait 48
m² totalement équipé qui n'existait pas
précédemment lorsque l'ancien patron a
pris sa retraite il y a 3 ans société
dépérissait peu à peu manuel a alors
racheté avec un associé toutes les parts
sociales de l'entreprise il s'est fait
aider par le Pôle Emploi Service de
plaisir pour constituer son dossier en
l'espace de 2 mois tout est en place
mais avec le recul cette période était
loin d'être une partie de plaisir la
première année c'était très très
compliqué et lourd en charge de
administratif et avec le recul là je
m'aperçois que c'est de plus en plus
facile et bon une fois qu'on a intégré
un petit peu toute la partie
administrative ça va beaucoup on va dire
mais c'est vrai qu'au début ça fait un
peu peur la première année on a du mal à
dormir en 3 ans manuel et son associé
ont développer leurs services Location
dépanage sur site une plus grande
palette de véhicules des nouveautés qui
fonctionnent et qui fonctionnent bien en
3 ans le chiffre d'affaires annuel a
presque doublé il sont encore décalés tu
vois alors que l'autre côté il a pas
bougé mais est-ce que ce serait parce
que le r il serait pas trop serré
peut-être Chang en tant ancien salarié
il a eu l'avantage d'assurer une
certaine pérenité avec la clientèle les
clients quand ils voient une figure qui
reste ça les rassure quelque part et ça
nous a permis par le bouch de faire
venir de regagner des clients qui qui
étaient on va dire réfractaires à
l'ancien gérant manuel et son associé
ont recruté deux personnes
supplémentaires et ont même ouvert il y
a un mois un autre magasin à
Saint-Germain en lait s'il avoue que
devenir patron impose beaucoup de
contraintes ce nouveau statut lui réussi
et lui plaît parfaitement il y a une
charge de temps additionnelle qui est
très
considérable mais bon on a la le
privilège on va dire d'être son propre
patron travailler pour soi donc on a
moins de comptes à rendre ok à demain
bonne journée au
revoir merci d'avoir été avec nous je
vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour un prochain numéro bonne
soirée